You might think that the
combination of science and
sport together is a relatively
new thing, but actually
they've gone hand in hand ever
since humans first started
playing games.
To ensure fairness, they would
draw a line in the dirt.
But to improve things and
ensure continuity
year-on-year, they cut two
grooves in a marble sill.
You would stand on the sill
and put your toes in the
groove before you started, hence
the saying "toeing the
line." It's one of the earliest
examples of sports
technology, and something
you can still see today
at Olympia in Greece.
Fast forward through history
and we crash into the
Industrial Revolution.
And for the first time, the
average worker had a little
bit of disposable income,
but there were
huge numbers of them.
And thanks to the new labour
laws they also had the
Saturday afternoon off, so what
to do with that time?
And the answer lies here in
Sheffield's Kelham Island
Industrial Museum, and on the
fantastic shelves over there.
So 19th century Sheffield was
a huge manufacturer of
cutlery, of hand tools,
and of cannon shells.
So at lunchtime on a Saturday
afternoon, the whistle would
go on the workers would clock
out using the clocking
machines over there.
They would then go down the pub
for a couple of hours, and
then pass through those
turnstiles there into the
football matches.
And that's why, traditionally,
football starts at 3 o'clock
on a Saturday afternoon.
The story is all there
on these shelves.
I give them feedback
that helps them
achieve their goals.
And that's the goals for that
session, the goals for that
training cycle.
And ultimately the goals that
will get them towards elite
performance, and hopefully
an Olympic medal.
So we've got the video of Ben.
This is the high-speed video
linked to the force plate
data, and we can play
the video through.
Oh, wow, I love that.
You can see the line projected
on screen.
And if the line's longer, he's
pushing harder, and depending
on what direction the line goes,
that's the direction
he's pushing into the towers.
So here, for example, you see
he's pushing back quite hard.
The drivers for this technology
have obviously been
interaction with computers,
gesture recognition, the sort
of thing that kind of normally
happens in a living room.
With sports engineering, we
can model a whole sport.
And we can use it to push the
physical boundaries of the
discipline.
Is it cheating?